- [Zac] "Halloween (2018)" is
filled with little references
and callbacks to the original "Halloween"
and its many sequels.
For example, take this
scene where a father
and son come across the
escaped mental patients.
Not only do their white outfits,
seemingly floating
around this foggy night,
resemble the escaped patients
from the original "Halloween,"
but listen to the song
playing on the radio.
- You all right?
♪ I wish I had you all alone ♪
♪ Just the two of us ♪
(kid gasps)
- This is the same song that
we heard Laurie Strode singing
as she walked away from the Myers house
on that fateful day 40 years ago.
♪ I wish I had you all alone ♪
♪ Just the two of us ♪
- [Zac] The amazing thing is
this isn't even a real song.
When speaking at Beyondfest 2014,
actress Jamie Lee Curtis revealed
that she just made it up,
which means for "Halloween (2018),"
they actually created the rest
of the song and recorded it,
just to include this Easter egg.
I've gone through the entire movie
and picked out all of its best secrets.
Once again, I will be
joined by "Halloween" expert
and horror YouTuber Jimmy Champane
who will be adding even
more "Halloween" insight
and knowledge.
- Hey, everyone.
Happy Halloween.
I'm glad to be back.
- [Zac] To learn the meaning
behind the new opening title sequence,
all of the "Halloween"
franchise Easter eggs,
my dark theory about Laurie
Strode and so much more,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
(rock music)
"Halloween (2018)" is not a remake,
but this episode of
"Things You Missed" is.
I first covered the movie
when it was still in theaters,
but since then I've noticed
many more hidden details
that I'm excited to talk about.
The "Halloween" franchise is
no stranger to second chances.
This movie is the second attempt
at making a direct sequel
to the original "Halloween."
The first was "Halloween II" from 1981,
which took place the same
night as the original.
This one acts as if that
movie never happened
and brings us into the world
of Haddonfield 40 years later.
Perhaps that's why we see a cop
playing "Back To The Future" pinball
before getting the call
about Michael Myers,
because this movie, like
"Back To The Future,"
is all about rewriting
the original timeline.
The "Halloween" timeline
is like a train map,
which I like to call
the Halloween Express.
I've done other videos
exploring alternate routes,
but this time we're just going
directly from "Halloween 1"
to the first stop on this
line, "Halloween (2018)."
In future videos, I will
continue down this route
to "Halloween Kills" and "Halloween Ends."
Despite going in a different
direction with the plot,
there are still
similarities and references
to all of the other movies.
"Halloween (2018)" is the
new "Halloween II" after all.
It's not a remake in the sense
that it has the same story and characters.
It's more of a reimagining.
What if Laurie and Michael did not meet
for another 40 years?
So, lots of aspects from
the original "Halloween II"
and everything else from the
last four decades do show up
in a slightly different form.
I'll explain further once we
get into the things you missed.
(dramatic music)
The movie opens at the mental
hospital, Smith's Grove.
One of the first images
is the pen of Dr. Sartain.
This pen ends up being important later on.
We focus on it again the next day
as he is getting ready
for the patient transfer.
And it's the same pen that
reveals a hidden blade
on Halloween night,
so he can attack the police
officer and free Michael Myers.
Perhaps this is
why there's a little
spinal cord ornament on it.
He's not literally stabbing
Deputy Hawkins in the back,
but it is a back stab in the sense
that he betrayed his trust.
We see more shots around the hospital
as Dr. Sartain checks in
with one of his patients.
It's difficult to hear what's being said,
so let me turn up the volume.
- [Dr. Sartain] Did you have
a restful sleep last night?
- [Patient] Oh yeah, I did.
- [Dr. Sartain] Any dreams?
- [Patient] Nope.
- [Dr. Sartain] Sometimes we
don't remember our dreams,
you know?
- He's telling the patient
about how we don't always
remember our dreams,
especially those that aren't recent.
If you saw my episode on "Halloween II,"
you know that movie is all about dreams
and what goes on in the subconscious mind,
The whole movie is like a nightmare
that Laurie can't wake up from.
I think the doctor's
dialogue is there to tell us
that in this continuity,
"Halloween II" could be
considered nothing more
than a weird dream.
There's further confirmation later
when the character Dave makes this mistake
about Laurie Strode's family history.
- Wasn't it her brother
who like cold-blooded
murdelated all those teenagers?
- No.
That's just a bit that some people made up
to make them feel better I think.
- So, this is a little
meta-joke to the audience.
Allyson is clarifying that
the "Halloween II" plot twist
where Laurie and Michael
are siblings is not canon
to this new timeline.
Sartain takes the reporters
up to see Michael Myers
and ask Aaron, the male
reporter, to tie his shoelace,
so as not too upset one
of the mental patients
who has a fixation about untied laces.
I see this as another
message from the filmmakers
to the audience; don't expect
a stereotypical slasher
where the victims trip
over their shoelaces
in life or death situations.
This is the era of
elevated horror after all.
It's less about outdated tropes
and more about disturbing subtext.
Whether they delivered
on this tied shoes promise is debatable.
While it is true that nobody
trips on their shoelaces
in "Halloween (2018),"
there is a character who
gets killed after slipping
and falling on a hardwood floor.
But the moment is a useful setup
because the character with
the shoelace fixation,
Mr. Tivoli, plays a
bigger part in the sequel,
"Halloween Kills."
Aaron brings out the
original Michael Myers mask
to try to elicit a response,
but everyone besides Michael
seems to get riled up,
which leads us to the opening credits.
The classic "Halloween" title font is back
after being absent from
everything after "Halloween 4."
The opening credits introduce
Andi Matichack as Allyson,
Laurie Strode's teenage granddaughter.
It's her first role,
just as the world was
introduced to Jamie Lee Curtis
for the first time with "Halloween."
This is the first of many examples
of Allyson filling the shoes
of Laurie Strode in this movie.
You'll also notice the jack
o'lantern rotting in reverse.
This may sound like the name
of a post-hardcore band,
but the image represents
Michael Myers rising
back up to prominence after 40 years.
In fact, the design of the
jack o'lantern is very similar
to that of the original movie,
which many have suggested
looks like Michael in profile
holding up a knife.
After having no luck with Michael,
our Bri'ish repor'ers try to get Laurie
and her reaction to his impending transfer
to a new facility.
- You know he'll be locked
away until the end of his days.
- That's the idea.
- This is word for word what
Loomis said about his plan
to sedate Michael, so he can
barely sit up during his trial
in the first film.
- He'll barely be able to sit up.
- That's the idea.
- [Zac] I know Laurie thinks
that Dr. Sartain is the new Loomis,
so much so that she outright says so
as if she were an audience
member watching this movie.
- You're the new Loomis.
- But in many ways,
Laurie is the new Loomis.
Be it her stark belief
that Michael is nothing more than evil,
her obsession with destroying him,
her willingness to pull up and
scream at trick-or-treaters
who just end up seeing
her as a senile old lady,
or her resourcefulness to
shoot and blow up Michael,
there are certainly a lot of parallels.
We're introduced to her
family shortly after.
Her son-in-law, Ray, is setting
a mouse trap under the sink.
I think this is a
foreshadowing of the ending
where it's revealed that
Laurie's house is one big trap
for Michael Myers.
- It's not a cage, baby.
It's a trap.
- [Zac] Pretty sure it's
still a cage though.
When Allyson and her
friends walk to school,
the whole scene is an homage
to a scene from the original
where Laurie walks home with
her two high school friends.
At one point, Dave stops
and blows up a pumpkin
with a firecracker.
- Go, go, go, go, go!
Happy Halloween!
(pumpkin explodes)
- This moment foreshadows
the end of the movie
where Laurie drops the same line
before releasing the
flare into the basement
to blow up her masked adversary.
- Happy Halloween, Michael.
(dramatic music)
- [Zac] "Halloween" is back this year
with a brand new installment.
And if you've been with
the "Halloween" franchise
for a while, you might
remember the novelizations
that came out alongside
Halloweens one through four.
For the new 40 year trilogy,
the novelization are back,
but this time you can get them on Audible.
Each novelization expands
on what we saw in the movie.
The "Halloween (2018)" novelization goes
into the financial woes of Smith's Grove,
the lost journals of Sheriff Brackett,
and even what happened to the
Myers house over the years.
Audible offers an incredible
selection of audiobooks
across every genre,
from bestsellers and new
releases to celebrity memoirs,
mysteries, thrillers, motivation,
wellness, business, and more.
You'll discover exclusive
Audible originals
from top celebrities, renowned experts,
and exciting new voices in audio.
Members get a free title every month,
or two if you're an Amazon Prime member.
Those titles stay in your library forever
regardless of membership.
This month I'm reading
"All Good People Here"
by Ashley Flowers
because horror stories
about missing children
in a small town will
never stop being creepy.
To try out Audible Premium
Plus free for 30 days
visit audible.com/czsworld
or text czsworld to 500-500.
You'll find that link in the description.
Audible.com/czsworld.
(dramatic music)
After Allyson tells about
her grandmother's history
with Michael Myers, her
friend Vicky suggests
just ignoring the holiday altogether.
- If I were you guys, I
wouldn't celebrate either.
I would just put up a
Christmas tree instead.
Just skip all over the
creepy Halloween shit, right?
- Uh, no.
That's a terrible idea.
But it might explain why
Laurie's daughter, Karen,
wears a Christmas sweater
for the rest of the movie.
I know I don't have to tell
this to "Halloween" fans,
but in my last video I
got a lot of questions
about what happened to
Laurie's daughter, Jamie.
This all goes back to the timeline.
Because "Halloween 4" never
happened in this continuity,
Jamie was never born,
and Laurie has a daughter
named Karen instead.
The scene inside Allyson's
class is another homage
to a classic "Halloween" scene.
You can pretty much count
on almost every scene
from here on out to be motivated
by sickening amounts of nostalgia.
Allyson sits in the back left seat,
the same position that
Laurie sat in in 1978.
The lesson is about fate,
just as Laurie's was.
Guess they haven't updated
the curriculum lately.
They also did this exact
same thing in "H2O" already.
The twist in "H2O" is that
Laurie is now the teacher.
This time, the teacher is played
by another familiar voice.
- [Teacher] Now let's open our books
to Frankel's interpretation.
He said, "Fate took a different course."
- Allyson's teacher is not seen,
but it's actually a vocal
cameo from PJ Soles,
the actress who played Lynda
in the first "Halloween."
Just as her grandmother
did years before her,
Allyson looks out the window.
But where Laurie saw Michael Myers
standing there ominously,
Allyson sees Laurie
waiting to meet with her.
This is part of the main
tenet of this movie,
the idea that the rolls of the hunter
and the hunted could be
reversed through perseverance.
And this is what the
British reporters came
to Haddonfield to investigate.
In his recording, Aaron
poses the question,
"Could it be that one
monster has created another?"
Later into Halloween night,
Dr. Sartain shares his theory
that both Laurie and Michael are vying
to become the predator.
- Michael's pursuit of
Laurie Strode could be
what keeps him alive.
I would suspect the
notion of being a predator
or the fear of becoming prey
keeps both of them alive.
- [Zac] Now we're seeing Laurie
has taken Michael's place
as the person standing outside the school,
and the movie contains many other examples
of the roles being reversed,
mostly during the finale.
In 1978, Laurie hides in the closet
while Michael stalks the
house searching for her.
But in 2018, Michael is
hidden somewhere in the house,
and Laurie is the one
investigating a shuttered closet.
In '78, Michael's thrown off the balcony
after being shot by Dr. Loomis.
He's left lying in the yard,
but on closer inspection, he vanishes.
But in 2018, the rolls are reversed,
and Laurie is tossed from
the balcony in a scuffle.
Michael sees her lying on the
ground in a familiar position,
but after looking away
momentarily, she has disappeared.
In '78, Michael's face
appears in a dark door frame
to scare Laurie, the
coolest shot in the movie.
But in 2018, after Karen
shoots The Boogeyman,
it is Laurie whose face
emerges from the dark
to strike fear into Michael.
In her spare time, Laurie is
shown to practice shooting,
and essentially turns her
house into a fortress.
She uses mannequins for target practice,
and after completely blowing
the head off this one,
uses the boobs as bullseyes.
There's also a little kid mannequin.
Very cool, Laurie.
Very cool.
There's a nice detail after this,
which is barely noticeable
in the final cut.
Laurie has a big scar on her left shoulder
from where Michael cut her
sleeve open with a knife
in the original movie.
There is a deleted scene where
we get a better look at it.
She was not the only one to
take on damage that night.
When we see Michael at
the mental hospital,
there's a small scar visible on his neck.
This is the same spot where Laurie got him
with the knitting needle
all those years ago.
As long as I'm bringing up deleted scenes,
even they have a couple Easter eggs.
In one deleted scene,
Aaron scares Dana with
the Michael Myers mask
while she's showering,
because apparently in
some alternate version
of this movie they were a couple.
In "Halloween: The
Curse of Michael Myers,"
there's also a scene where
Michael sneaks up on someone
in the shower.
Another deleted scene shows a dog
who became a Michael Myers victim.
It's a common "Halloween" trope
for one of the earlier
victims to be a dog.
It happens in the original,
"Return of Michael Myers,"
"Revenge of Michael Myers," and
Rob Zombie's "Halloween II."
Michael and several other
patients are being transferred
from Smith's Grove to another facility.
The idea of the patient transfer comes
from "Halloween 4: The
Return of Michael Myers,"
where Michael is loaded into a van,
and the trip has a similar outcome.
This time it's a blue school bus,
which is a reference to
"The Purge" season one,
a fellow Blumhouse production.
I guess this was just
the year of blue buses
because they did the blue
Fortnite bus in YouTube Rewind,
and Mr. Beast did it too.
- Fortnite and Marques Brownlee.
- Is this what you wanted?
(Laurie screams)
- [Zac] This was the
first "Halloween" title
to be made by Blumhouse, so
they decided to cross promote
with one of their big
properties, "The Purge."
The most recent film at the
time was "The First Purge,"
and it features a big
"Halloween (2018)" poster
in a character's room.
Allyson's boyfriend, Cameron,
is played by Dylan Arnold.
He's also from "The Purge."
The two are planning their
Halloween costumes as a couple.
- So, we're going as Bonnie and Clyde.
- You know how it ended, right?
Their story ended with the
bullets and the bleeding.
- That's probably a foreshadowing
of the end of this movie.
Sure enough, it does end
with bullets and bleeding.
But they aren't just
going as Bonnie and Clyde.
Cameron will be rocking a skirt as Bonnie,
and Allyson complete with
neck tie will be Clyde.
It's Bonnie and Clyde but
with the roles reversed,
a symbol of the role reversal
between Michael and Laurie
where Laurie becomes the hunter
and Michael becomes the hunted.
To foreshadow this switch,
the filmmakers feature the
reversal of traditional male
and female roles all over Haddonfield.
For example, remember
that kid and his father
who came across the bus crash?
They're on the way home
from a hunting trip,
a typically male dominated activity.
And the kid is complaining
about how he's upset
that he had to miss his dance class,
a typically female activity.
There are three main love
interests in the movie;
Allyson's boyfriend, Cameron,
Vicky's boyfriend, Dave,
and Karen's husband, Ray.
They're all kind of sissy boys.
Cameron throws his
girlfriend's phone in pudding
because he can't have her attention.
Dave lets his girlfriend go upstairs
to investigate a strange
noise instead of him,
and it leads to her getting killed.
- Would you go look?
- [Dave] Do I have to?
- [Zac] And Ray lets his
mother-in-law take the lead
while he does nothing
to protect the family.
None of these so-called
men take any initiative
in their relationship.
Dave even puts a special
emphasis on the date
when he and his girlfriend
are gonna lose their virginity
and gets a tattoo of it on his shoulder.
I don't know why, but to me
that just sounds like something
that a 15 year old girl
would find romantic.
Now nobody's saying that
being a girly boy is a good
or bad thing.
My only point is
that traditional gender
stereotypes have existed
for millions of years and
these characters ain't it.
- I'll pop your cherry.
- I do not wanna know what that entails.
Also, Allyson's Clyde costume plays
into her becoming the new Laurie.
She starts suited up with
a blazer, hat, and tie,
but as the night goes on,
she loses any accessories that
might be slowing her down.
And in the final shot,
she's left with a blue button up shirt
with the top two buttons undone,
which leaves her looking
a lot like Laurie did
when she was Allyson's age in 1978.
During a dinner to celebrate
Allyson's academic achievement,
there's this kind of bizarre
picture of a white horse
in the restaurant.
The white horse was part of a big metaphor
in Rob Zombie's "Halloween II."
This is either a reference to that
or just they wanted a picture
of a horse in the restaurant.
Laurie is also depicted in the scene
to have kind of a drinking problem,
just like her character
during the restaurant scene in "H20."
Allyson's dad also talks about
how he used to know Cameron's
father, Lonnie Elam.
Lonnie is actually a minor character
in the original "Halloween."
He's one of the kids
who teases Tommy Doyle
about The Boogeyman.
We see more of him later
in "Halloween Kills."
It is not long after her arrival
that Laurie goes into freak out mode,
which leads into a flashback
where we see what it was
like for Karen growing up.
And the house contains
a ton of hidden secrets.
(thunder cracks)
(suspenseful music)
Laurie shows up late to the dinner,
and she's acting a little strange.
She's emotional after seeing Michael
during the hospital transfer.
- I saw him.
The Shape.
- She calls him "The Shape."
If you're a "Halloween" fan,
you know that The Shape is
Michael's character name
in the end credits of
"Halloween" one, two, and six.
I believe this is the first
time a character refers to him
as The Shape in universe though.
I kind of like that they acknowledge
that somebody actually calls him that
without spoiling the mystique.
It's still up to the viewer to decide
what "The Shape" really means.
They have to send Laurie home,
and Karen finally tells her daughter
what her childhood was like.
There are a ton of cool
details in Karen's room.
Next to the window,
we can see a little bit
of this poster frame,
the James Ensor painting. You
can get a better look at it
when we come back to this
room at the end of the movie
where we can also see the
black globe on the desk
and the hat hanging on the wall.
All three of these are items
that Laurie had in her room
as a teenager and held
onto over the years.
There's another scene later on
where Laurie shines a
flashlight into the room,
and we see a heart-shaped pillow,
another relic from
Laurie's room 40 years ago.
Before I move on, there
are a couple more points
that I wanna make about the kid
who discovered the crashed
patient transport bus.
I'm really getting my
mileage out of this kid.
He's in the movie for like two minutes,
and I already pulled three
things you missed off of him.
After getting out to look for
his dad, he re-enters the car
where Michael Myers is
now waiting for him.
Michael chokes him from behind.
This is the exact same way
that Annie Brackett died
in her car in "Halloween (1978)."
As Michael slams the
kid against the window,
we get a rare glimpse at his face,
and you can see his left eye
has that clouded over look
that you sometimes see
with a blind person.
This is the eye that Laurie
poked out with the coat hanger
at the end of the original.
It's a little hard to see in this movie,
so here's a behind the scenes photo.
One of the things I've
been keeping track of
in each of my "Halloween"
"Things You Missed" episodes
is the location of Haddonfield
within the state of Illinois.
The original took place
around the southern tip
near Hardin County, but both sequels,
"Halloween 2" and "Halloween (2018),"
place Haddonfield in Warren
County off to the west.
The next day is October 31st, Halloween.
It's the best day of the year.
Our British reporters have decided
to visit the grave site of Judith Myers,
whose headstone has been
restored to its rightful place.
I noticed this one big
recognizable gravestone
that says Sinclair,
because I remembered looking into this
when I analyzed "Halloween 1"
to see if it was anyone important.
It wasn't, but the fact that
this is here in 2018 means
that they either went back
to the exact same spot
or created a graveyard set
with great attention to detail.
Either way, job well done by someone.
If anyone is an expert on trees,
let me know if it's possible
that this skinny tree could have grown
into this massive chonker of a tree
in the 40 years between these movies.
Sorry for calling it that.
I got a little carried away.
(computer beep)
Another similarity between the
films is the groundskeepers.
In the first one, the
guy tells Loomis a story
from the nearby town Russellville.
In this one, the groundskeeper
talks about her cousin
who works in another
cemetery in a nearby town.
That morning, Deputy Hawkins
discovers Michael Myers is one
of the escaped mental patients.
On the document he's holding,
the patient is listed as Michael A. Myers.
The middle initial A stands for Audrey,
which is a reference that
not many viewers know about.
The original "Halloween"
was filmed in 1978
and released that same year.
It became very popular, so in 1980,
NBC bought the rights to
air the film on television.
It was only 91 minutes,
so NBC asked John Carpenter to
film a few additional scenes
to fit a two hour time slot
so they could show more commercials.
That's where they reveal
Michael's middle name, Audrey.
- I have no choice but to
remand Michael Audrey Myers
to the Smith's Grove
Warren County Sanitarium.
- Next we've got another
set that pays homage
to scenes of "Halloween" past.
The gas station that
Aaron and Dana fill up at
brings to mind the gas station
that Dr. Loomis stops at
in "Halloween 4."
This is where Michael attacks a mechanic
to steal his jumpsuit in both movies.
If you look closely,
Michael is actually the
driver of the brown truck
that pulls up on the far
end of the parking lot.
Michael also hijacked a
brown car in "Halloween."
We can actually see him crossing over
to go into the service shop
while Aaron has his back turned,
then again when Dana steps into the store.
If you look through this window,
Michael can be seen attacking the mechanic
in the background.
Next to where Aaron is refueling,
a red van pulls up from
Resurrection Church,
and there's a strange woman inside.
This may be one of our only references
to the eighth "Halloween" film,
"Halloween Resurrection" from 2002.
(static rumbles)
I also want to note that
when Michael Myers stranded Dr. Loomis
at the gas station in "Halloween 4,"
it was a strange Reverend
whose car was decorated
with religious stickers who picked him up.
Before meeting the Reverend,
he tried to hitchhike
with some cheerleaders
in a convertible, but
they left him in the dust
when he got close.
There is a deleted scene
from "Halloween (2018)"
that seems to reference this moment,
but it's definitely
referencing another moment.
Listen to what the
cheerleaders are chanting.
- We're from Haddonfield,
couldn't be prouder!
Can't hear us now?
We'll yell a little louder!
- I guess some traditions never die
because this one goes back
to the first "Halloween."
- We're from Haddonfield,
couldn't be prouder!
Can't hear us now?
We'll yell a little louder!
- There are so many similarities
between these scenes.
In both movies, characters start talking
about the Halloween dance
immediately after walking
away from the cheerleaders.
The high school's sign has been updated,
but they're still short on black letters,
so they use a few red ones.
Details like this are
why this movie is
considered a requel by fans.
It's technically a sequel,
but it feels like a remake
with how repetitive it is.
At the time, I compared it to
"Star Wars: The Force Awakens"
which basically does the same thing.
It's a requel of the original "Star Wars."
"Jurassic World" was a
requel of "Jurassic Park."
All three of these were
insanely profitable,
so now requels are everywhere.
So, the homages, callbacks,
whatever you wanna call them,
they just keep coming.
Like, every 45 seconds or so.
Dana steps into the ladies room
where she's attacked by Michael Myers.
That's a reference to
"Halloween H2O: 20 Years Later,"
where that same thing happens.
Aaron comes in to save her
but he gets his face bashed
into the bathroom wall.
That's a reference to the
"Halloween" remake directed
by Rob Zombie.
I find it somewhat interesting
that Michael bashes in
the face of this reporter
in order to regain his iconic face,
or at least William Shatner's iconic face.
Yeah, I've never stopped
thinking about this guy
on my original videos who said,
"Micheal does not have Shatner's face.
"It's the other way around."
What the hell are you on, man?
Suppose Shatner's mom
could somehow dictate
how her baby's face came out.
She would also need time travel.
Shatner was born in the '30s,
almost 50 years before
"Halloween" came out.
With Michael's costume complete,
he's ready to do some trick-or-treating.
I hope you're not tired
of the constant callbacks
to previous "Halloween" movies
because this next part is
something I like to call
"the 'Halloween II' sequence."
Three minutes and 45 seconds
of pure nostalgia pron
for Halloween's 1981 sequel.
It starts with these two kids.
The one on the left is
dressed up as a pirate.
"Halloween II" had a pirate
kid who went to the hospital
after getting a razor
in his Halloween candy.
The kid on the right is a
cowboy holding a boombox
on his shoulder, and
he bumps into Michael,
but Michael ignores him
and continues on his way.
This exact thing happens in "Halloween II"
before Michael makes
his way to the hospital.
Then Michael goes between
these houses to snoop around.
You can hear some kids
singing in the background.
♪ Black cats and goblins
and broomsticks and ghosts ♪
♪ Covens of witches with
all of their hosts ♪
- This is actually another
"Halloween 1" reference.
It's the same chant that we
hear at the very beginning,
right after the opening titles.
♪ Black cats and goblins
and broomsticks and ghosts ♪
♪ Covens of witches with
all of their hosts ♪
- [Zac] Then Michael goes into
the shed and gets a hammer.
The first weapon he
acquires at the hospital
in "Halloween II" is a hammer.
I think the existence of the
"Halloween II" sequence goes
back to what I said earlier,
because this movie represents the start
of a new timeline branch,
this is the new "Halloween 2" in a sense.
In H2, Michael broke
into the Elrod's house
where Mr. Elrod is watching TV.
The TV is also on here in 2018,
but the program is the
1982 series "Voyager."
This show is about a
pair of time travelers
who go back to repair
errors in world history.
In other words, they are
altering the timeline,
just as David Gordon Green, Danny McBride,
and Jeff Fradley are
rewriting the timeline
of the "Halloween" franchise
by taking out plot points
that they consider to be errors,
such as Laurie and Michael
being related by blood.
"Halloween (2018)" in a way reminds me
of Steven King's "11/22/63."
You can go back and change certain events,
but there are still inevitables
that are going to happen no matter what,
which is why the "Halloween
II" sequence continues
with even more things you missed.
(thunder cracks)
(dramatic music)
Michael's next victim is Mrs. Elrod,
a woman in a pink bathrobe
with hair curlers,
making a ham sandwich.
She's an homage to Mrs. Elrod,
the woman that Michael
steals a kitchen knife from
in "Halloween II."
- Mrs. Elrod?
Mr. Elrod?
Are you okay?
- We don't see Mr. Elrod
in "Halloween (2018),"
but there is a reference to him later on
when Allyson's friend Oscar is drunk
in the Elrod's backyard.
- Happy Halloween, Mr. Elrod.
- [Zac] 2018's Mrs. Elrod is not as lucky
as her H2 counterpart,
and after finishing her,
Michael continues through the house
where we hear a crying baby.
But Michael does not bother
going after the baby,
which may be a nod to the
original and the 2007 remake
where Michael ignores kids
and babies during his spree.
Outside, a couple dressed as a doctor
and nurse are leaving their house.
- Wait, hang on, hang on.
I don't have my stethoscope.
- [Zac] "Halloween II"
takes place at a hospital
in Haddonfield, so you
can bet there are plenty
of scandalous nurses there as well.
This is also a setup for "Halloween Kills"
where these characters would
come back in a bigger capacity.
But instead of going after them,
Michael turns to his right
and stares through the window
at this woman talking on the
phone to someone named Sally.
- [Woman] Hey, Sally, how are you?
- [Zac] Mrs. Elrod's neighbor
in "Halloween II" is also
on the phone with a girl named Sally.
- Sally, I can hear the sirens coming.
- Judging by the conversation,
this woman is also learning
about the latest incident
in Haddonfield during this phone call.
- [Woman] Really?
That's awful.
- And in both movies,
Michael sneaks up with a little surprise.
(woman screams)
And that is the three
minutes and 45 seconds
that I collectively refer to
as the "Halloween II" sequence.
After that, it's straight back
to "Halloween 1" memories.
No "Halloween" requel would be complete
without at least one babysitter,
since the only reason
that Laurie and Annie
ever encountered Michael Myers was
because they were
babysitting across the street
from each other.
This time, Vicky is
babysitting a kid named Julian,
or as I like to call him, the
best character in the movie.
Her boyfriend is already
on the way to join her
for a spicy evening.
And Allyson and Cameron are
supposed to stop by after that.
She's setting up a very similar
scenario to what went on
at the Wallace household in 1978,
where Annie invites her boyfriend,
and Lynda and Bob used
the house to get busy.
However, like in "Halloween 1,"
things don't go according to plan.
While Allyson and Cameron are
attending the Halloween dance,
presumably the same dance
that Laurie hoped Ben
Tramer would take her to,
Allyson sees Cameron kiss another girl,
and she storms off causing
him to chase after her.
I'm not sure if this is
an intentional reference
or anything, but it sure
is a lot like this scene
from "Halloween 4" where
Rachel Carruthers gets upset
after seeing the boy
that she's interested in
with the Sheriff's daughter
who's wearing this "cops
do it by the book" shirt
and basically nothing else.
As a result, they break up,
so the after party is limited
to just Vicky, Dave, and Julian.
Oh, and one other guest.
(suspenseful music)
(Vicky screams)
Cops are called,
and we hear the following
communication go out
over police radios.
- [Radio] All units, we have reports
of a domestic disturbance
at 707 Meridian Avenue.
- This is another little
Easter egg for movie fans.
The original "Halloween" was filmed in
and around Pasadena, California,
and 707 Meridian Avenue was
the address of the Myers house.
You can still visit it and
many locations from the movie,
like the corner store
and the Strode house.
Speaking of the Myers house,
when I made my initial
video in this movie,
I assumed that the dollhouse
in Karen's room was a replica
of the Myers house.
"Halloween (2018)" was still
in theaters at the time,
so I didn't really have the
opportunity to compare it.
And it does look kind of similar,
but upon closer inspection,
it's clearly not.
The Myers house doesn't
have these dormers.
It doesn't have a window
above the front door.
And the inner layout is not similar at all
to what we see from "Halloween"'s opening.
It's not the Myers house,
but that didn't stop certain websites
that like to steal my writing
from saying that it is
without actually checking for themselves.
No surprises there.
Interestingly, there's another
little light blue house
in the background
during the interview scene
in Laurie's living room.
It is also not the Myers house,
but it's not identical
to the dollhouse either.
I think the dollhouse just
represents Karen's childhood.
Karen always wanted to be a normal kid,
but Laurie wanted to train her for combat.
At the end of the movie,
the dollhouse is lit on fire
after Karen uses her training
to help defeat Michael.
The image represents Karen
trading a normal childhood
for protection all of these years later.
One "Halloween" film
that doesn't often get referenced is
"Halloween III: Season of the Witch"
because it's the only one
that's completely disconnected
from the rest of the franchise.
The movie is about the mystery
of an evil mask making company
known as Silver Shamrock.
This scene in "Halloween
(2018)" shows trick-or-treaters
wearing the three Silver Shamrock masks;
skeleton, jack o'lantern, and witch.
Deputy Hawkins shows up
at the house Vicky has
been babysitting at,
outside of which we see
a clothesline covered
in hanging white sheets.
You'd be hard pressed to find anyone
who doesn't use a machine to
dry their clothes in 2018,
so I see this as a slight
nod to the original
where Michael Myers stalks Laurie
from behind a clothesline.
When I covered the original "Halloween"
on "Things You Missed,"
I talked about how this is part
of a psychosexual metaphor,
but in just about every
episode since then,
I've pointed out more
examples of hanging sheets.
It's pretty much become
a "Halloween" tradition
at this point to have them
show up somewhere in the movie.
Another use of white sheets,
both in the original
"Halloween" and this movie,
is the bed sheet ghost costume.
This time instead of
using it as a disguise,
it's used as a red herring.
Michael drapes it over Vicky's corpse
for Deputy Hawkins to discover.
Vicky is also set up in a
chair next to a fish tank.
It's like when the nurse
discovers what Michael did
to Dr. Mixter in "Halloween II."
Next, Hawkins goes downstairs to find Dave
who is pinned to the wall with a knife,
the same fate that Bob Simms
suffered in "Halloween."
If all of these repeated scenes
and homages weren't enough,
there are also numerical references
to other "Halloween" movies.
The cop car that shows up for
reinforcement is number 1078.
The babysitter murders took
place in October of 1978.
Deputy Hawkins vehicle is 1098.
So, that would be the month
that "Halloween H2O" took
place; October, 1998.
And yes, that means this
movie is technically
"Halloween H40: 40 Years Later."
Can't wait for H6O.
Laurie shows up to warn Karen
and Ray that they aren't safe,
and they leave a message for Allyson.
- There is a police officer
waiting at your house
to bring you to us.
We're all gonna be together.
Now do as I say.
- She used these same words 40 years prior
to protect Tommy Doyle
and Lindsey Wallace.
- I want you to tell
them to call the police
and tell 'em to send 'em over here.
Now, do you understand me?
Go, do as I say!
- Part of the reason this "Halloween" was
such a big event in the horror world was
that horror movies were at near
peak popularity at the time.
This was only a year after "It"
and two years after "Lights
Out" and many other bangers.
In fact, it seems the writers
of this new "Halloween" were
very inspired by "Lights
Out" as the scene with Oscar
and the motion censored
light features Michael
at a standstill when the light is on,
but he creeps up close to his target
each time the light goes off.
This is exactly how the
antagonist Diana gets you
in "Lights Out."
This wasn't the first or last
movie to borrow this concept.
But whether this imitation
was a form of flattery
or theft is ultimately
up to you to decide.
But I think it's theft.
I was amused to see that
"Halloween" takes another page
from "Lights Out" later in the movie.
The mannequin scene where
Laurie is looking around
for Michael in the house
is very reminiscent
of the factory scene
at the beginning of the
feature film version
of "Lights Out."
After seeing Oscar get "The
Virgin Suicides" treatments
on the Elrods' fence, Allyson
runs, screams for help,
and begs a neighbor to let her inside,
the same reaction that teenage Laurie had
to seeing her dead friends.
The difference is that
Allyson actually gets someone
to let her inside.
Maybe we can chalk this up to
the existence of technology
in the '10s that would've
allowed the neighbors to know
that Michael was on the loose
and Allyson probably wasn't pranking them.
The final act of this movie
would contain more info
about the true intentions of Dr. Sartain,
and I have my own theory
about a dark secret
from none other than Laurie Strode.
(thunder cracks)
After picking up Allyson,
Deputy Hawkins heads towards
Laurie's fortress of a house
to get her to safety when he
comes across Michael Myers.
He decides to floor it and
try to run Michael over,
the same tactic that Rachel used
at the end of "Halloween 4."
This is where we get the
first big twist of the movie
where Dr. Sartain attacks
him to prevent him
from injuring Michael any further.
We were led to believe
that Dr. Sartain was the new Dr. Loomis,
but in fact, he may be the new Dr. Wynn,
the cult leader from
"Halloween" five and six,
who essentially acts as Michael's handler.
Looking back,
there are a few clues about
Dr. Sartain's true allegiance.
I already mentioned the
significance of the pen,
but before the patient transfer,
Sartain almost seems to be
trying to comfort Michael.
- Don't worry, Michael.
I'll be by your side.
- [Zac] It's already well established
that Michael's a sociopath, so
there's no reason to do this.
It's evidence that
Sartain has grown attached
to his patient. He even
fights to be on the bus,
most likely a sign that
he had something to do
with helping The Shape make his escape.
- Michael Myers is still my patient
until he's in somebody else's care.
So, I'm seeing my duty
through until the end.
- And finally, when Hawkins suggests
that he's going to kill
Michael if he gets the chance,
Sartain tries to convince him otherwise,
even though it's clear
that they'd be risking the
safety of the townspeople.
- [Dr. Sartain] Remember,
he's property of the state.
He mustn't be harmed.
- Sartain's motive is an interesting case.
He's a psychologist
that probably needs his own psychologist.
He's become so obsessed
with understanding Michael
that he sees value in putting on the mask
and seeing what it's like to kill.
- So, this is what it feels like.
- [Zac] The fact that he puts
on the mask himself seems
to pay a tribute to the
original producer's cut
of "Halloween: The Curse of Michael Myers"
where Dr. Loomis discovers
Dr. Wynn left behind
with the iconic mask at
the end of the movie.
Dr. Sartain's care for his
patient is not mutual however,
and he gets his head stomped in,
a fate that he shares with the trash guy
from Rob Zombie's "Halloween II."
All of this seems to suggest
that Dr. Sartain is the one
who sabotaged the patient transfer
that allowed Michael to get free.
It's obvious based on his motives
that he must have had
something to do with it,
but I find it curious
that we never actually see the bus crash
that started all of this.
My theory is that Laurie
played a hand in it as well.
We know that she went there with a gun
to see the patient transfer,
and it's safe to say that
she's mentally unstable.
At one point, she even admits
that she wanted to see Michael escape.
- Do you know that I pray every
night that he would escape?
- [Zac] The fact that
this part of the night is
so deliberately not shown
in the edit makes me think
Laurie may have cut off the bus
with her car, causing it to
crash in a roadside ditch.
Then Dr. Sartain took the
opportunity to use his pen knife
and fight off the security
guards or the driver.
As a result, the confrontation
doesn't go the way
that Laurie had planned,
and she shows up at Allyson's
dinner emotionally distraught.
There is a moment where Laurie
sees news about the crash
on television the next day.
WCZD.
Nice. Many people took this as
proof that she didn't do it.
But if you actually look at this scene,
she has almost no reaction.
She doesn't even turn to look at the TV,
which suggests to me that she
already knew what happened.
Going back to the scene
where we see her scream,
who is this figure approaching the car?
Could this be after she's
already driven the bus
off the road and now she
doesn't know what to do?
In my initial video, I did
see a few comments saying
that test screenings
did actually show Laurie
as the one who caused the bus crash.
But since that footage didn't make
the Blu-Ray deleted scenes,
maybe that's a twist that they're saving
for "Halloween Ends."
Later on, there's a scene
away from the action
where two cops get into
this weird conversation
about Bahn Mi Sandwiches.
The only reason this
conversation seems to be
in the movie is to make these
cops look kind of goofy.
I think it's supposed to be a parallel
to "Halloween 5: The
Revenge of Michael Myers,"
where these two cop characters
are always accompanied
by this goofy circus music.
It's pretty bizarre.
The cops are killed in the squad car
while stationed outside of Laurie's house,
similar to how the
"Halloween 5" cops are killed
while stationed outside
the teen Halloween party
at the farm, which is also bizarre.
I'm gonna throw it over to Jimmy
who has a few things
you might have missed,
including who this police
officer character really is.
- The cop who brings his
own brownies is played
by Christopher Nelson.
And he's done makeup
effects work on everything
from "Avengers: Infinity War,"
all the way down to these
new "Halloween" movies.
He also created the masks
you see in "Halloween (2018)"
and in "Halloween Kills,"
even the flashback mask,
which I think looks really good.
The ending of "Halloween (2018)"
was not always the ending
that we have today.
This point is about where this version
and the original version
of the film diverge.
The outcome in both
versions of the movie is
pretty much exactly the same,
but instead of shooting
Michael in the face
from the top of the basement stairs,
Karen actually shoots
him on the front porch
with a crossbow.
And after he takes a pretty savage beating
from both her and Laurie,
he stumbles off into the
woods and sits on a stump.
Now, I haven't actually
seen the full version
of the original ending,
but if you look back to the
trailers for "Halloween (2018),"
they used a lot of the footage,
so you can kind of stitch
it together yourself.
And from what I've heard,
both Laurie and Michael
are in really rough shape
in this cut of the movie
to the point where it's basically implied
that both of them die.
But of course, when
Blumhouse and Universal saw
how good the movie was turning out,
they decided to alter
the ending a little bit
to leave it more open
for potential sequels.
And then it made $250 million.
The story continues on.
We get "Halloween Kills"
and "Halloween Ends."
- Ultimately they did reshoots
so that the final
confrontation could go down
inside the house.
So, to set this up, Laurie
covers the front door
in order to try to give
her daughter time to hide
in the basement when this happens.
(glass breaks)
The way that Michael reaches
through the front door
for her is an amped up version
of him smashing his hands
through the shuttered closet
and reaching for Laurie in "Halloween."
After shooting her way free,
Laurie and Karen take
cover in the basement
where Laurie has kept
this old gun labeled KS
for Karen Strode.
Michael would soon arrive.
- Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
- Wrong Michael.
It's kind of weird
how they didn't really think
Laurie's house through.
The basement is located under the kitchen.
And at one point she shoots
up through the floorboards
at Michael.
But when we actually see the
kitchen from the top side,
it's not floorboards, it's tile.
As I mentioned before,
the roles are reversed,
and Laurie is now the hunter.
This room is identical
to the master bedroom
where Laurie and Michael fought
at the end of "Halloween,"
but instead of Michael coming in
to find the balcony
door open, it's Laurie.
She follows in Michael's
footsteps by going to the closet,
but rather than finding Michael,
she discovers her son-in-law, Ray.
His corpse is stowed in the same position
that she found her
friend Lynda in in 1978.
Michael emerges from
the dark to attack her,
and she disarms him by jamming
her thumbs into his eyes.
In the original "Halloween
II," she was able to blind him
by shooting him directly in the eyes.
And in the 2007 remake,
Michael blinds Dr. Loomis
by forcing his thumbs
through his doctor's eyes.
After Karen's childhood gun
training pays off in a big way,
Michael is knocked into
the basement by Laurie.
When he sits up, it's in the
same fashion as his recharge
after being stabbed by Laurie
in the Doyle's bedroom way back when.
That's what's crazy
about "Halloween (2018)."
In their quest to find more
and more classic moments
to include, they end up
including little mannerisms
that nobody ever paid much mind to,
like the way Allyson puts
her hands over her ears
after hearing a gunshot being a trait
that she inherited from her grandmother.
In the beginning of this video,
I discussed how "Halloween (2018)" is
kind of a second attempt
at making "Halloween II,"
and I think the ending solidifies that
because both movies end
with Laurie playing a part
in blowing up her evil counterpart,
and both of these films
could have been the end
of the franchise with Michael
presumably burning to death,
but neither of them are.
I don't know if this was intentional,
but when Laurie drops the
flare into the basement,
I couldn't help being
reminded of the sheriff
dropping the dynamite down
to try to blow Michael up
at the beginning of "Halloween 5."
Allyson, Karen, and Laurie
are rescued by a pickup truck,
which again,
I couldn't help but think of
our good old Illinois boys
from "Halloween 4" who
pick up Rachel and Jamie.
The final shot shows the three generations
of women huddling in
the back of the truck,
and Allyson has not let go of the knife.
My interpretation of this ending is
that the evening's events
have turned Allyson
into a fighter.
All her life, her family has seen Laurie
as this weird paranoid old woman,
but now Allyson is going
down that path herself.
The very, very last thing
we experience is the sound
of breathing at the end of the credits.
(masked breathing)
It's not just breathing though.
It's the sound of
breathing against a mask,
which we heard shortly after
Michael first laid eyes
on Laurie in the original.
At the time, this was
the only proof we needed
that "Halloween (2018)"
would have a sequel.
So, join me for the next
episode of "Things You Missed,"
where I'll be breaking
down "Halloween Kills."
And if you wanna hear why you're wrong
about "Halloween (2018),"
make sure you check out Jimmy's
"Halloween (2018)" Revisited
and come on, he's making
some great content.
Go ahead and just
subscribe to his channel.
If you're excited for what is in store
for the finale in "Halloween Ends,"
make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld
because I'll absolutely
have an in-depth video
on that one as well.
Ring the death bell and
select all notifications,
and I will see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.